in what areas does the European
Commission and its Directorate General
for health and food safety carry out
audits primarily in the area of food
safety but also on food quality topics
such as organic production and quality
schemes secondly systems of animal
health and welfare and animal feed and
thirdly plant health and plant
protection products like pesticides the
audits cover production in the EU and
imports a key priority concerning plant
and animal health is to see if effective
systems for crisis preparedness and
management exist as disease outbreaks
can have serious implications for health
and the economy the Directorate General
for health and food safety also conducts
audits in human health areas on
organizations certifying medical devices
for people such as hip implants or
pacemakers on active pharmaceutical
ingredients from non EU countries and
importantly on measures aimed at
reducing antimicrobial resistance the
auditors also do a lot of non audit work
generating overview and other reports to
share important data this provides
feedback to the EU legislature in
updating current legislation or
developing EU policy for the future
based on its audit and analysis work the
auditors also contribute to training
initiatives for staff in EU and non-eu
countries to ensure that EU standards
are met they also liaised with non EU
food safety organizations to help design
international food safety and control
standards thus overall the European
Commission's audit work has an impact in
several air
by helping to ensure high levels of
safety through effective controls and
enforcement systems and feedback to
legislators it supports the global trade
of safe products facilitates jobs growth
and investment a deeper and fairer EU
internal market and most importantly
consumer safety